Brad's more of an activist than you
might think we're all equal that's it
and that's everything but we're supposed
to help the most vulnerable another's
freedom is every bit as important as our
own in fact on the site be undefeated
one african-american writer asked is
Brad Pitt the Locust white man in
Hollywood
why welp its production company Plan B
has championed a lot of important
stories about the black experience in
America he was a producer on Selma about
the civil rights struggle and moonlight
which told a same-sex love story in
black communities and the oscar-winning
12 years of slave which he briefly
appeared in that doesn't mean much to
anyone
it seems yours might mean a lot to a
whole lot of people just subject matter
we haven't focused on and I think this
is part of our DNA that we have and if
you really want to understand Brad's
commitment look at this that's where the
levee broke right on the other side of
this house after Hurricane Katrina
Kevin met with Brad in New Orleans where
Pitt helped build new homes in the Lower
Ninth Ward the project has recently run
into a slew of problems but there's no
denying Brad's commitment we're people
who are very fortunate and if we can
share a little that I think it's um
there's no greater gift meanwhile Brad's
ex Angelina just announced she's
donating two hundred thousand dollars to
the n-double-a-cp Legal Defense Fund
which is the organization behind the
legal work that helped topple
segregation and continues to fight civil
rights battles angie turned 45 yesterday
and we're told she spent the day with
her six children in quarantine a source
tells ET the mother and activist has
recently been having difficult and
necessary conversations with her
children about race
[Music]